stop a Papa welcome back everybody I
should not be singing to another
wonderful oh we uncovered some dark
secrets about our parents their house
doesn't have any blood in it why don't
we loot all this a lot of client that's
good you know I'm gonna keep looting
something's up with our parents we don't
really know what yet I suspect that they
have been putting fart juice in our food
which has actually been helping us all
alone but something is definitely oh you
could you could say that again
that's my Jimmy impression or Timmy they
all have the same names let's get real
here an attack on the SP PD police
station last night has left citizens in
shock and disbelief with prisoners now
on the loose and policemen in the
hospital one member of the Chamber of
Commerce has had enough and is
announcing his bid for mayor go around
voting on people dead together we can
free ourselves from the anal terrorism
that has been forced upon us my name is
Mitch Conner oh and I enjoyed it is that
a transgender hand going into politics
because I mean it's 2017 and I'm not
really surprised but at the same time
just wanted to make sure mitch is okay
you know what my god I can never do this
bit I did it I don't have a thing oh wow
oh
[Music]
Tom's feel like you have no idea what to
do next you haven't been given any
direction and you're unsure what's even
going on and no not without it's because
you've been trying to find yourself in
the wrong way knowing your sexual
identity or race or ethnicity that's
nothing compared to knowing who you are
spiritual hairiness go to the pod okay
someone is waiting for you at the pond
who will finally help you find your true
self it's gonna be more pedophiles isn't
it well let's do the side quest it seems
like the game is telling us to do the
side quest and I want to know who I am
as spiritually obviously Christian or
Swiss chin as I like to call it
Swedish Christian thank you very much um
I'm surprised we haven't done it before
I thought we were gonna do it like early
in the game because you were deciding
what kind of character you wanted to
make I think we might use one of the
teammate stations
[Music]
it's jimothy I keep forgetting is
pleading name all right this is the pond
okay we can go there
it's the pond where the first game ends
in where we throw the stick of truth in
spoilers a spoiler alert it's a big
piece of the plot just like there you go
there you go buddy we getting a lot of
questions about my invisible headphones
they're not for sale you can't get it
look you I'm gonna play with fire - hey
man where's Jasper he's in trouble
good talk what in the world another fast
travel okay that's good
we have to walk all the way Oh get over
here yes yes yes yes
what's up I believe we can help each
other okay have you heard of the super
best friends well it is I a powerful
superhero with the amazing ability to
talk to fish and swim its
seamen that see man it is my job to help
all creatures of the sea and right now
there is a gay fish who wants help
getting his mother its Oh No all the
other super best friends keep saying
they're too busy
will you help yes of course then swim
down to the water's depth with me don't
worry my water defenses shall protect
you
he's gonna drown us isn't he the new kid
dives down through the water protected
by seamen oh my god I like a support
made fun of cement before seamen before
oh my god it's Eman and yes I do this
child has incredible powers all right if
you get my mom into heaven I will give
you three million dollars and some
jewelry just touch my little gay flipper
and we shall be magically transported to
help her I thought Kanye West would be
in it for a minute so seaman sidekick
had to help the gay fishes mum fly to
heaven on a stream of rainbow unicorn
we're playing flappy birds
oh my god we're playing flappy bird this
is 10 times better however oh I can't go
too high this is kind of nice honestly I
hope not
oh wow it's going it's going real fast
you're going so fast all they move now I
[Music]
don't want to mess up Natsu Oh No
and so Lehman sidekick has to help the
gay fishes mom fly to heaven on a stream
of rainbow unicorn oh my god oh I see
it's app isn't it a parody of it's a
parody of Kanye West's game how did I
not hit me oh that's brilliant he's
making a game about his mom going to
heaven all the gays fishes mom of course
it all makes sense how do i dodge this I
am but he's shooting me with [ __ ]
flame are you serious oh thank thank
thank you game Thank You game that's
quite enough I get it thank you did I do
it my god what a skill I take so it is
Kanye West what is that
it's James add on very well by John
grace JQ yeah no not you seamen the kid
hey man oh yeah right anyway you had no
reason to help this little gay fish my
child and yet you did that's right every
reason to help me I'm a lyrical genius
voice of a generation
I see that you were trying to determine
your spirituality my child allow me to
help thee there are good and bad in
every religion my child
which are you Rastafari Satan
Scientologist seek Unitarian Christian
Chris okay you're a chaotic Christian
that's me
finally you want a selfie with Jesus
right of course Jesus thank you for
making it less awkward for mailed you
know who you are now you are one step
closer to believing in yourself my God
thank you Jesus hashtag blessed that was
amazing I love the side quests in this
game every time they show up chaotic
Christian chaotic Racine Scandinavian
that's me
dank leaders why are you talking like
that dialogue tree got you we don't take
kindly to your types around here let's
welcome this fan to our town
they triggered imprinted welcome nugget
alright let's just kill these guys
really quick I don't we've done it like
four times I don't think there's that
much to see okay we dealt with that we
chose a religion chaotic Christian I
love this like I said I want to do more
side quests it's definitely worth it I
know your mind blown now that we're
friends on the grams in real life but
keep it cool oh right I almost got hit
by them he's in trouble maybe we should
tell his parents or something dude he
probably just found some porn anyway
Jesus called but he needs to respect
artistry this social media platform does
not respect artists don't talk to me
then impose game oh she's back where's
the camera set up there
thank you classy
[Music]
can't wait to use that okay well let's
go to the what would they call friends
freedom fighters whatever whatever they
are freedom palace that's it
freedom fires has said it's too obvious
well it's in this great
I wonder who I wonder this was someone
who wanted to hurt us yes it was an
image I didn't exactly and I say new kid
or you will never see your parents again
and hurry or else they'll be more no
stop it it is too much where is who you
man catch the new kids you took the new
kids parents because you hate that we
merged with Freedom House that's not
true
I want this mega franchise more than
anybody tell him dad
you have five seconds Cartman I'm on
your side
yo kid you believe me don't you
Oh Timmy how are you gonna get update Oh
No
ah thanks Timmy you
[Music]
wait what what Timmy Timmy Timmy No are
you serious right now
I can you tell him it to me that I can
use any oh my god that one's really good
that one's really good that one's okay
oh my god this changes the game
[Music]
yeah no you said it before and it's kind
of awkward every time okay let's keep
going we have all the classes now in our
back story is complete we saw our
parents having sex no wait we saw our
dad talking her man
have you guys ever walked in you know
what don't answer that
luckily never happened to me go to the
place where people get their copy figs
better hurry tick tock tick tock snake
attack if it did happen I probably
blocked it out of my memory I know it
was left and right well there's only
those ways to go isn't it I know it's
closed it's what I'm trying to say
should be quiet please
is the inside probably yes I don't know
if you're a hero or a menace man this
coffee really has me buzzed
hello it's for you oh wow that's real
good new kid but now I'm gonna make
things a little harder on you okay
telling you where to go
I'm giving you a riddle you ready yes a
place where death comes in all shapes
and sizes go into this door to find what
your prize is Oh Maggie dear I'm so
wasted on this stuff
that riddle it's impossible
oh no not the [ __ ] in yes I do think
yes I do
[Music]
you have made many enemies in this town
vigilante and now you have to face that
he took our jobs
that was no not crappy but now you go
cross the line this should be
interesting
damn wish I had a titty mag oh damn look
at that damaged dog ah damn boy it
wasn't that interesting actually haha
sorry is normal battle I don't think you
guys need to see everything as solve
Connors death store riddle now where
could that possibly be
[Music]
hey thanks for being the only one who
believed me of course why would I not
believe oh my god for now just do what
he says
suspicious I can't fast travel anymore
I think the abortion center which is a
lovely place to go and last time we went
there it was weird I still remember that
from the first game my god every time I
close my eyes I just imprinted in my
retina no no thank you thank you
we're almost there Oh any time now
that's a rhino place where's the
abortion clinic then unplanned
Parenthood I don't listen to her okay
that's not true
excuse me excuse me while I this is
where I need to be we got some new stock
which is a rare treat with our funding
have a fabulous day you want to feel the
baby kick that sorry kind of
interrupting a tender moment here kid I
suppose not
well then I don't know god damn it no no
sure you don't understand it how could
you
what's the gay face doing they say
that's my great challenge that's the
weight on my shoulders to bring
understanding to the people you
understand well I but how could you
you're working from an old model I'm an
original you know artists come up to me
all the time and already you get
inspiration and that's all wrong because
I don't get inspiration I always had it
I popped
I was in game [ __ ] day one original and
gay fish is something that can't be
changed because it's inside me and all
around me it's like air or water but see
I ain't scared because I know
tomorrow I will be [ __ ] game
[ __ ] immutable this just seems like a
nice life yeah she hit some columns we
all hit some columns and columns on the
way up to heaven on a [ __ ]
unicorn I didn't see anybody else's mama
riding the unicorn to heaven while we
was up there did you know because that
was some original [ __ ] in conclusion
that's why you gotta let gay fish okay
like some kind of weapons yeah we're
here not really that you see the guy
standing over there take a selfie with
him do it now your mom is gonna suffer
someone's calling me sorry it's not a
game vigilante you're gonna get somebody
killed but let's take a selfie anyway
[Music]
you're gonna have to stop one more
riddle and the place where seats hang
from chains part desert part jungle
where happiness reign
wait there's another riddle oh my god
thank you this is all Connor supporters
oh my god why cm ham kid oh that was it
okay the community center where is that
god damn boy when who is the community
center here we are at the community
center alright one two I feel like
there's gonna be some pot with that it
is actually a nice Cartman oh my god
what have you done with the new kids
parents badass nothing yet but when I'm
finished with you I can't say they'll be
exactly safe this has gone far enough we
end it now
the only thing about the end is you
mysterious what this is like a smash man
we're actually fighting Mitch Conner
okay so your parents got kidnapped but
no I can totally relate as a kidnapped
victim myself all right funny okay I
can't actually reach him from here
No damn it
alright let's just sit our turn damn yes
a lot of healthy then who did it is he
not there I can't see this is another
weird thing like I can't go over there I
can't see whatever I'll just stop here
[Music]
my muscular body this must be like to
freight at stage bias because it
otherwise is too easy
oh okay guess what
oh my god he has a fart ability yes of
course of course it's Connor Cartman I
believe II we can use
even the new kid and turn his back on
you teen Wow pretty up Oh guys I'm not
that will decrease your movement dude
Oh No nice it's pretty easy
uh-oh he's on fire nevermind okay
alright okay okay no be quiet
you seem to be taking all the damage
after further calculations that damage
didn't happen
what activate again what all right we
need a good damage hold I don't know if
Craig has it yeah he does
oh man that's really good oh yeah yes
the little hamster love it it's so cute
it's the best one you're only hurting
yourself oh whoa what the hell it's
gonna sting damn he's strong man he
ricochetted my damn it what you get to
mix up dan I take it back man he's
really strong no stop come on No
I swear to God if he says that doesn't
count
come on Jesus thank you
this is really tricky man I almost
messed up even pathetic yeah I'm chill
great now she skips a turn great so make
me hella anxious yes I said hella that's
how much you make it okay all right let
me just kill him
I want to counter them police police
work
yes oh that feels good finally
he's dead right no no no thank you
[Music]
what's gonna happen at you never knew
oh no he's got its muscular yeah
sometimes torture is the only answer
you're gonna torture me for what
everyone get back to Freedom House base
we have to make this [ __ ] talk what
are you talking about guys it's me the
key
they played him like a damn fiddle
[Music]
I'm on I'm literally here I'm literally
outside okay let's get in very nice
sounds they got here very nice merriness
a very a nurse okay let's see what this
is this is a but it's wrong with you
guys I'm not your enemy you're going to
talk Cartman new kid you're going to
have to make Cartman talk are you gonna
do it
oh my god he's gonna fart in his face
you guys are wasting your time
I'm the king torture doesn't work
against me remember that's true he
doesn't watch you eat is that it I'm not
afraid
the burrito of course he hate the
aluminum foil as well
I'm pressing part you will tower Cartman
I will eat the broccoli name the octopus
[Music]
hit him again
ah yes
what cats I just remembered the fries
jog my memory said he must he was what
to genetically alter the cats the
genetics laugh doctor mephesto yes that
must be attack yes
alright let's check it out in the next
episode thank you guys so much for
watching another one I don't know let's
do a save there and I'll see you guys
tomorrow as always it's quite a fan